we have to hunt and kill to survive just
like the animals out
here dead ch right
here
look like the Wolves came along and
hamstring it or they're right around
here
somewhere I'm traveling along with my
snow machine looking for a place to do
some wolf snares and I come up a dead
looks like a calf moose from what I
could see there's some blood it might
have been bit around the stomach or the
back leg and there's a lot of snow right
now the Moose are real vulnerable and um
I don't think they could survive much if
they're attacked by a wolf or a pack of
wolves so I'm guessing what I'm seeing
right here is a a place where a moose
had getting chewed up by a wolf and just
kind of died if I find something like
this is unfortunate I don't like to see
this happen to the Moose but it's part
of the cycle of life right here but the
Wolves would be back though for sure the
wolves are most likely right around here
is my guess and they'll be back tonight
this is part of nature out here the
Cales the weakest ones that get killed a
lot especially in deep snow I mean you
look at the snow out here if you walk
out here just right off the trail it's
deep and then you go want to where the
Willows are hung it's it's this deep out
here and that the calf really has no
chance against predators out here and um
it's unfortunate this time of the year
to the numbers of moose get knocked down
and that's what uh predators are doing
out here is hunting
moose so I'll keep moving I'll just
leave it the way it is and start looking
around for Wolf
Track
when it comes to food with us a the
Baskin moose is number one staple of our
diet and that's the number one staple of
the wolf too you're talking between six
wolves and 15 wolves in one area that's
about the standard siiz pack and when
you have a standard siiz pack like this
they kill about a moose of week so you
do the math on that that's a lot of
moose they kill over a SI period of time
when you have a pack of wolves in your
area or multiple packs you lose a lot of
moose population around your area so
traditionally we really have a big part
of our culture as wolfing or Predator
control especially in the winter when
the Moose are most vulnerable it's kind
of like how humans have cattle in
certain areas they have to take care of
their cattle with us moose is our cattle
so we have to look out for that animal
we can't just hunt Moose and not look
out for the Moose itself we got one
snare up here I'll check it out see some
Fresh Tracks going in so might be
promising
tracks going back
here put the snare kind of far back
here oh trying not punch
through there little
trench see where they went through the
top
here
oh holy I got
on holy
anab beautiful wolf I don't want to rip
it away too hard because it's frozen
down it's a good siiz
wolf and see Tiana Tiana is
Wolf I got to get this out of
here when I put out wolf sets I don't
always expect to catch something and
once you're able to have that luck where
the animal come to you you have to
really show your appreciation for that
Animal by saying thank you because I
know how much it means to my
people there's only a few of us out here
that can do that and I feel proud to say
I'm one of them blessed to have that
wolf bring itself to me this way it's I
really truly believe
that I just keep moving keep checking
sets and when I'm done I'll start
skinning got a lot of daylight it's warm
out on the bu
[Music]
SE